moving on our main story tonight
concerns utilities specifically electric
utilities the company is responsible for
delivering us power and also giving us
the creepiest mascot ever created ready
kilowatt a hell creature who for decades
appeared in ads for over 200 electric
companies like this one about him
emancipating woman in the home and this
one where he tells a housewife don't
kill yourself it ain't worth it reddy
even appeared on children shows where he
undoubtedly gave a whole generation
nightmares what's going on here ha ha
you should know that you can expect
anything to happen here mr toot boy i'll
say
hey what's happening now
those peanuts they're floating in the
air that's my new electrostatic
generator get out of there mr toot
that's the only time i've ever been
scared for a clown we can't actually
show you the rest of that video because
and this is true if you watch it until
the end ready shows up behind you and
brutally murders you
now you probably don't give too much
thought to your local electric utility
but if you do it might be because
they're charging exorbitant rates for a
basic human necessity as this north
carolina pastor explains
one of the founding members of this
church sister linda jones she literally
cut her pills in half skipped days
in order to pay her life bill god bless
her so she passed on and there are
hundreds of people
right around here who need that help
that is terrible and in case it bumped
you at all you're right that was a
property brother that you just spotted
there
he made a documentary about utilities
and it's actually pretty good to the
point that you're even going to see a
little more of it later on and if you're
wondering which property brother that is
i'll give you a clue it is the
circumcised one
and if you don't know which property
brother is circumcised you're clearly
not that big a fan of the property
brothers
and high bills are just the beginning of
the problems here because utilities are
also exceptionally prone to scandal in
fact just google your utility company
right now and the word scandal and
chances are they've gotten into some
major trouble it's basically like
googling your local jimmy john's and e
coli or the name of your favorite
teacher from high school on january 6th
you're not gonna like the results that
you find
and at their worst utilities can even be
deadly take pacific gas and electric one
of california's largest utilities we've
talked before about the 2018 campfire
the deadliest wildfire in california
history and how it all started when this
hook holding up a pg e transmission line
broke causing the line to ignite the
brush below eventually decimating
several nearby communities and leaving
85 people dead pg e has since paid fines
and settlements but it's still very much
in operation despite the fact that
wasn't close to the only scandal that
they've been involved in as this
reporter will tell you
this is a company that was fined
hundreds of times and faced more than
two almost three billion dollars worth
of fines you know if pg e was an
individual and not a corporation i think
by now they would be in prison
there's just been repeat offenders
they've been on probation they violated
the probation the problem is you can't
take a corporation and put into prison
yeah he's right you can't even though
many corporations clearly deserve to be
imprisoned from enron to purdue to any
company that insists on talking like a
sassy [ __ ] on social media hellmann's
once tweeted you're in their dms we're
getting spread on their bread and why
you don't need to do this hellmann's you
can just be mayonnaise
but pg e is not only not in prison it is
still supplying power to millions of
californians who have no choice in the
matter and if you're thinking how the
[ __ ] is that possible that is what this
story is about it's about the incredible
amount of power that we give to
utilities how weakly they can be
regulated and the damage this can do and
let's start with the single most
important thing to know about utility
companies which is that for most of us
they're actually the only game in town
if you want to go buy an iphone or any
other kind of consumer product you go
out to a store and you have a number of
choices
with electricity in most of the country
you really only have one choice and that
company has a monopoly
exactly in our modern economy you are
supposed to have choice just look at all
the streaming services out there if
there's a blockbuster 2.0 superheroes
and old racism anime probably crashing
on you right now no idea no idea and
until recently news quibby that is
arguably too much choice
but utilities operating as natural
monopolies dates back to the fact that
around the start of the 20th century we
needed to build a nationwide power grid
from scratch and that obviously required
a huge investment companies were only
incentivized to do that with a guarantee
that they'd be able to operate in a
non-competitive environment and at the
time that made sense but those
monopolies persist to this day and
mostly as for-profit investor-owned
companies now in exchange for giving
utilities a deal that sweet we did put
some restrictions in place the law says
that they should spend the least they
can while providing quality
environmentally safe service which
sounds great because it caps their
ability to make too much money but and
this is a huge but there is a carve out
because when they build something a
piece of physical infrastructure they
are allowed to then pass along that cost
to you through your bill plus
an additional percentage they get to
keep as profit usually around 10 percent
and this creates a clear incentive the
bigger the project like a power plant
the more profit they make as this
activist explains big monopoly utilities
get a guaranteed range of a rate of
return on their capital expenditure so
like a waiter in a restaurant where
there's a guaranteed tip the more that
is spent if you buy dessert or you get a
bottle of wine the more money they're
going to make
right if your profit is pecked to doing
certain things you're going to make sure
that you do those things more it's just
like if hbo only paid me for every time
i got weirdly horny for an animal except
that's actually a bad example because
the show would pretty much look exactly
like it already does not now not now i'm
trying to make a point
go away before i change my mind
goodness gracious
and in the best case scenario this might
mean that utilities are investing in
infrastructure that is badly needed the
problem is they can also be shameless in
increasing spending even when it is not
needed or on projects that are actively
falling apart take south carolina when
utilities there tried to add two nuclear
reactors to an existing plant the
project's cost spiraled and a massive
federal investigation later revealed
that executives at south carolina
electric and gas and its parent company
knew the project was facing major delays
and cost overruns but withheld that
information in order to keep it going
meanwhile local customers paid more than
two billion dollars in the form of
higher bills for a project which by the
way never generated any power
and some working on the project at the
time were troubled by what they were
seeing just listen to this leaked
voicemail from a vice president at the
parent company who later became a
whistleblower in which she tried to warn
her colleagues about what was happening
they are mismanaging that project and
it's a jaw's expense they're doing it
because they want to make money and
they're propping up earnings to be able
to make their um bonuses
and it's going to be at your expense
yeah that's pretty shocking isn't it not
just what she's saying there but also
that people still leave voicemails
absolutely no one should be doing that
anymore in fact every voicemail greeting
should just be sorry i missed your call
please don't leave a message after the
tone just text me instead because it's
not 1997.
and overspending isn't the only way that
utilities incentives can wind up
screwing over customers because they can
deliberately stifle innovation that
might make power cheaper or be a net
benefit to society as this solar power
executive will tell you now solar is
becoming real these utility monopolies
are saying wait a minute we got to crush
it before it gets too too big they want
to build more plants so they can make
more money and if we take a little bite
out of that apple and we say hey guys we
got solar panels everywhere on all these
homes and you don't need to build that
many more power plants then the utility
goes well wait a minute how am i going
to make more money next year yeah
exactly people putting up solar panels
and generating their own electricity
threatens the anti-competitive structure
of a utilities monopoly so they're
obviously going to try and step in and
block it who wants competition it just
makes things harder you think i want to
compete with euphoria or love island or
this youtube video of ducks annihilating
a bowl of peas
[Applause]
you could be watching that on a loop
right now instead of watching this show
you idiots why are you still here make
better choices
some activists have even used rooftop
solar as a way of challenging the
monopolies in their states remember that
church from earlier where the pastor was
talking about people cutting pills in
half to make ends meet well in 2015 to
help cut costs it partnered with this
local non-profit and in an attempt to
challenge the laws on the books the
nonprofit installed a small solar panel
system on the roof of the church at no
upfront cost
financing it by selling electricity to
them at about half the rate to their
utility duke energy charged now similar
arrangements are permitted in other
states but not in north carolina and
duke energy pushed back hard asking the
state's regulators to issue a cease and
desist to the non-profit and invoke its
power to find them up to a thousand
dollars a day for every day it sold
power to the church and in the end duke
energy got what they wanted that
church's solar arrangement was shut down
and any hope of replicating it in the
state was squashed and when circumcised
property brother asked duke about this
whole saga their response wasn't great
faith community church wanted to test
regulation in north carolina by doing
something that was basically illegal
they were trying to pick a fight
you could say that they had a good setup
to get publicity this was a
african-american church and we're a big
utility and we're a target and sometimes
there are groups out there they're not
trying to advance policy they're trying
to get media attention and they they did
a good job here are there situations
where as a human being you have a
conflict as a utility company where
you're saying this is how it has to be
versus
maybe there's a bigger picture with
something that's broken
i think that's just the way it has been
wait wait wait just the way it's been
has historically never been a great
justification for something still
happening in fact there is only one time
that that works as an argument when
you're talking about the milwaukee
brewers sausage race now
why do a bunch of sausages race around
the fields before the bottom of the
sixth inning because that's just the way
it's been it doesn't make sense and may
it never change long live the racing
sausages
and there are examples all over the
country of utilities getting in the way
of people using solar energy the
argument being if people start leaving
the grid and generating their own power
then over time the cost is going to go
up for everyone left behind and look
there is a longer conversation to be had
about the proper way to build people who
use solar panels but making it cost
prohibitive is definitely not the answer
and if you're thinking shouldn't there
be someone who can rein these companies
in well in theory there is most states
have public utility commissions they are
responsible for things like signing off
on any big investments proposed and also
overseeing the setting of rates
unfortunately many of them are badly
outmatched by the utilities that they're
supposed to regulate and this can have
major consequences a few years back
mississippi power ran into massive cost
overruns on a new plant that it was
building which was initially expected to
cost 1.8 billion dollars but ended up
ballooning to seven and a half billion
and in hindsight there were obvious red
flags that you would hope the state
commission would have been more wary of
from the very start just listen to a
company representative explain his side
of the story
can you tell us
why
the project
is over budget and also behind schedule
i would tell you that if we made any
errors in judgment at all any missteps
is that when we took that proposal to
the commission we were only at between
10 or 15 percent of design
and so i think it's
the little engineering that we had done
at that particular point in time that
has sort of come back to haunt us a
little bit in terms of cost and schedule
wait let me get this straight
the plant was only 10 to 50 designed and
the commission let it go ahead anyway
that is not how designing complex energy
plants should work that's not even how
designing lego sets work that's why
you've never seen one called a little
tree and you figure out the rest
now in mississippi's case the problem
seems to have been a commission rushing
to approve a project without doing
proper due diligence but in other cases
like alabama's state commission the
problem seems to be ideological it has
been described as one of the most opaque
politically motivated and
environmentally hostile commissions in
the country their commissioners are
actually elected and i do want to show
you one campaign ad for the woman who is
currently running it
twinkle's priority is our priority jobs
we need more conservatives like twinkle
who put jobs first twinkle is a proven
conservative republican who has stood up
and fought the liberal special interest
in washington conservative republican
twinkle andrus kavanagh our way of
fighting back
yeah
that woman is named twinkle that is her
actual given name as in when she was
born her parents were asked what do you
want to name your baby and they
genuinely replied twinkle definitely
twinkle
she even confirmed this story yourself
saying my daddy thought i needed a fancy
name it may be cute for a three-year-old
but it gets old and honestly i could see
how being called twinkle could get older
for a while but let me just say this
twinkle for everyone who isn't you
calling you twinkle will never get old
it will
never get old twinkle
and look i'm not saying that twinkle is
a bad commissioner because she's called
twinkle i'm saying that twinkle's a bad
commissioner because for one thing when
there was a push for more open hearings
on electricity rates in the state she
outright said i want to exclude the
environmentalists from taking part in
the process and suggested that
environmental extremists only wanted
these open proceedings so they could
trot out their fancy san francisco
environmental lawyers and junk science
hucksters and the thing is it's not just
twinkle when one of alabama's other
commissioners chip beaker again real
name
because it seems alabama's utility
commissioners must by law sound like
hannah barbera cartoon characters
when chip beaker was running for his
position he wrote in an op-ed the
so-called climate change crisis is about
as real as unicorns and little green men
from mars which is obviously ridiculous
because climate change is very real and
unicorns sadly do not exist which i know
is not ideal although if you're in the
market for a majestic creature with a
lot of horn
this guy
may be able
to help you
and look having a commission run by
science denying ideologues is bad enough
but in other states public officials can
appear fully in utilities pockets take
ohio a few years back a big utility
there first energy was caught up in this
massive scandal
ohio house speaker larry householder and
four others have been charged with
racketeering accused by the feds of
funneling millions from the energy
company into a 501c4 dark money group
called generation now okay first
generation now sounds like a failed 90s
boy band whose members are all now
spokesman for different cryptocurrency
companies but
very basically what happened there is
that first energy funneled 60 million
dollars to the speaker of the ohio house
to get him to pass a bill hb6 that has
been called the worst energy bill of the
21st century now i have to tell you the
house speaker in question denies
wrongdoing and is still awaiting trial
but what is very clear is that first
energy was working extremely hard to
influence the decision-making process
they actually paid the chairman of the
state's utility commission 22 million
dollars in consulting fees in the years
directly preceding him becoming their
regulator and while he denies doing
anything improper i will point out that
on the very day the bill passed first
energy ceo wrote to him saying and i
quote
hb6 [ __ ] anybody who ain't us which is
very cool right and just so you know the
man who wrote that is this guy who looks
like he's left lengthy reviews for
multiple gas grills on homedepot.com
this man wrote the words [ __ ] anybody
who ain't us this
old white man take those precise words
with his old white fingers
so look to recap our utility system
largely consists of for-profit companies
with monopolies over an essential
service building as much [ __ ] as they
possibly can so they can pass the cost
along to you on your electric bill and
to see just how bad all this can get
let's go back to pg e arguably
california's most hated company in fact
a quick skim through any pg e affiliates
yelp page gives you just a taste of that
because you'll find reviews like
absolute [ __ ] show [ __ ] garbage
company
[ __ ] you pg e your day will come
and my personal favorite the actual
technicians lovely often hot to boot
phone people hit on this either
dismissive and stupid or thoughtful and
kind corporation itself evil empire
personified
which is a lot more nuanced than you
typically find in yelp reviews look i
understand that the lowest ranking
smoking hot employee that i interface
with isn't to blame for the company's
larger structural problems but for the
record [ __ ] everyone in the c-suite with
a cactus
and you can see why californians hate pg
e so much in just one three-year time
span it was responsible for around 1500
fires that's an average of more than one
fire a day and at that point pg e a
lesser utility and more a fire company
that occasionally also delivers power to
people's homes
and so many of pg e's problems stem from
the way that they are incentivized to
operate because remember their profits
are paid to money that they spend on new
infrastructure that they build not on
what they spend maintaining it or the
area around it and when you don't
maintain equipment eventually it fails
that old hook that broke and started the
campfire was 97 years old and it's not
even their only hook that was
dangerously worn down
this hook found a couple miles up the
line from where the campfire started
shows just how bad things got a groove
more than halfway through the metal from
decades of grinding against the hole it
hung from
holy [ __ ]
decades of grinding isn't exactly a
phrase that you want to associate with a
vital piece of our power grid
it's barely a phrase you want to hear at
your grandparents 50th anniversary i
mean you're happy for them right it's
obviously what's kept them together for
so long you just you don't want
to hear it
and it's not like pg e didn't have the
money to perform basic maintenance
because in the five years before the
campfire it issued over five billion
dollars in dividends to shareholders
look clearly this isn't a system where
you the customer are going to be
prioritized if anything the model only
makes sense if the company's
shareholders are viewed as the customer
and your bills are the product
and what you would hope elected
officials in california would crack down
on pg e many take money from them and
don't seem to see anything really wrong
with that just watch as california's
governor blows off a pretty pointed
question pg e was convicted of a federal
of six federal felonies in 2016. after
that you took more than two hundred
thousand dollars to help get elected how
should people trust you to be running
the show to come up with the solution i
um i i wish you luck with
whatever you're working on but uh that's
a strange question
wait is it though
is it because that seemed pretty
reasonable to me it's not that reporter
asked mr governor why do you think the
wiggles had princess diana killed that
is a strange question there was no big
red car anywhere near the scene but what
he just asked you deserved a proper
answer and yet frustratingly if you live
in california and pg e is your provider
there is nothing you can do
every time you turn your lights on you
are reminded that your utility has
killed people and the only real recourse
you have is giving them a shitty yelp
review so how do we fix this well if we
were able to start our power grid over
from scratch what we would probably do
is make utilities publicly owned and run
by the government it wouldn't fix
everything things might still go wrong
but you would remove so many of the
worst incentives here unfortunately
transitioning now would be hugely
expensive and in all likelihood isn't
happening anytime soon but there are
smaller steps that we should also be
taking in the meantime for instance
instead of having a system where
utilities are incentivized just to build
stuff we can incentivize them to work
directly in the customer's best interest
by investing in things like maintenance
renewables and energy conservation this
is something known as performance-based
regulation and several states are
already trying it now as for the
regulators look commissions will
unfortunately probably always vary in
effectiveness depending on whether it's
staffed by people who actually give a
[ __ ] about this or let's say someone
named twinkle but
we have to make sure that
under-resourced regulators get more
support more access to technical
expertise and more jurisdiction over the
companies that they monitor and at this
point i would usually bring out a mascot
that we made for utilities that's
representative of just how terrible and
horrifying they are but amazingly i
don't even need to do that do i because
they already made a murderous hell demon
almost a hundred years ago with ready
kilowatt so all we really need to do is
simply bring ready back so ladies and
gentlemen
i'm thrilled to present to you the
glorious return of ready kilowatt
ready
ready ready where are you where are you
ready
yeah this is creepy i'm already
regretting this where is the clown ready
where's where's mr toot he's dead john
yep i killed him of course you did i'd
like to leave ready this is a bad idea
who said you could do that why [ __ ]
the world is my monopoly and i alone
control it okay you want to use your
refrigerator yes yes i do you want your
[ __ ] lights to go on and off yes i do
then your local utility is your gun
right i am your god
look i cannot believe i'm saying this
ready but you are actually too good at
representing how shitty utility
companies are oh you have no idea why i
could kill you right now and there's
nothing anyone could do about it don't
be nasty about it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what
happened to the lights blackouts happen
john no no you turn the lights back on
you freak
you can do it yourself john just go
ahead and pull that lever oh wait just
this one here uh-huh oh okay here it
goes
i am gonna get such a fine for that
that's our show thank you so much for
watching see you next week for another
episode of last week tonight with ready
kilowatt
[Laughter]
bye-bye
[Music]
[Laughter]
hahaha
you